Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
continuing in
the chapter of
vigilance of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
vigilance of Allah's observation
[Silence]
Here we have another narration
and these are three narrations in a row
which are all found in the 40 narrations
of
this is very important whenever we come
across a narration
as part of the 40 narrations
it's important for us to take note why
because the 40 narrations
of
they are the essence of
as a matter of fact the 40 narrations
are the essence of Islam. That's the
point of those 40 narrations. That
compilation of 42 narrations. It was
later added to by Raj. He added another
eight narrations. He made them 50. Those
50 narrations,
they are the crux. They are the
they are the cream of the crop with
respect to the fundamentals of all of
Islam. There is not one single concept
of Islam in the Quran or in the Sunnah
that cannot be taken back and refer back
to one of those 50 narrations.
So these narrations are very important
and this is why
students always start
with memorizing those 40 narrations.
That's what they begin with when you
want to memorize hadith. You begin
there. Are there other books that are
more authentic? Sure. Are there other
books that are a little bit more
precise? Sure. But that's not the only
consideration when committing
something to memory.
When we commit something to memory, we
want to make sure that we are committing
something to memory that the scholars
have mostly agreed upon. And so for
instance, if I were to
say, you know what,
I think that the 40 narrations of a Noah
We are good, but there are better
compilations.
So I'm going to go with those something
more authentic, something more
comprehensive, something more whatever
it is, that's fine and that's possible.
However, will you find as many
explanations
as you will on the 40 narrations of a
Noah? Absolutely not. The scholars
haven't worked on other books as they
have on that book. And this is an
important point to take into
consideration
when working on any piece of literature.
And so this is a third
narration in a row in which the Noah
mentions in his book that is
essentially an introduction to this book
which is the 40 narrations referred to
as al and
this narration is on the authority of
Iben Abbas.
Who is Iben Abbas? Somebody tell us
they've been our best.
Come on. You just want me to keep asking
over and over.
Okay. The prophet's uncle's son. Is
there an easier way to say that? His
cousin. Okay. So, Iban Abb is the
prophet's cousin saiam.
How many uncles did he have?
How many uncles did the prophet have
sudden?
What are their names?
We already got one.
Okay,
there's two.
There's three.
We said Abuab. There's four. is correct.
Those are four. So we have Hamzb Abdalib
Abbass Abdalib
Abu
Abdalib
and Abu Talibb Abd Muttalib. Correct?
Okay. So we notice something about those
four. Two of them were Muslim and two of
them
died as disbelievers.
The two Muslims, one of them
has a higher virtue than the other,
which is Hamza.
Not to take away from Abb,
but Ham is one of the first people to
become Muslim from amongst the prophet's
family. Sallallah.aii wasallam.
Relatively speaking, he became Muslim
later in the later years of Mecca, but
still way before Hijra.
And
was martyed in which battle?
Battle of correct. And then
Abbass
who is one of the wealthiest men of all
of the Arab peninsula in his time and he
had a number of sons. All of them were
Muslim Al Abbas and he has another
brother that narrates narrations. Do we
know who he is?
Al. His name is Alipb.
Okay, memorize it. I'm gonna ask you
guys this in the future. I don't want to
be talking to myself up here because I
already know these things. All right.
Okay. The next two we notice one of them
is more intense in his disbelief than
the other. It's almost a mirror of
each other.
We have Abu Lahab and Abu Talib. Abu
Lahab did everything he could to be a
thorn in the prophet's side.
Wasam. He did everything he could to
antagonize him, to belittle him, to
insult him, to harm him, even down to
the most petty things putting
putting stones and and sticks in front
of his door so that when he's walking
home at night, he might possibly trip or
cut himself. The most petty of things.
things that someone of his position
should be way above.
But his disbelief and the intensity of
his disbelief
is what stooped him to such lows.
And he died a disbeliever.
Does anyone know when he died?
Abu Lahab.
I mean, we know that he died a
disbeliever. And what's interesting
about Abu Lahab is that he was so
arrogant
that he wasn't even a very good enemy.
Think about it. His anger and hatred
towards the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam made him a pretty pathetic
enemy. He wasn't even good at being an
enemy. What do I mean by that? Well, for
instance, the prophet Sam
said,
right, the verses revealed
all he had to do
to try to
dispel the prophet sallall.aii
Wasallam's prophethood.
All he had to do was say, "Okay, you
know what? On second thought, I become
Muslim."
Right? This is a prophecy that I'm going
to hell. I become Muslim.
He wasn't even a good enemy. And that is
because
hatred, emotion when it drives a person,
not when it emotion is seasoning to
food.
The mo the majority of a person's
actions need to be driven by logic, by
evidence.
However, if a person is mainly driven
by emotion
and there is no substance to his there
is no logic, there is no forethought.
There is no strategy,
this person will have will be very bad
at whatever it is he sets out to do.
Emotion is something that is good in
small doses. The prophet sallall.aii
alaihi wasallam teaches us this.
The second is Abu Talib.
Abu Talib is a very interesting case.
There's a narration that is very curious
about Abu Talib. The prophet sallall.aii
Wasam said
he said that he
made dua for Abu Talib
and Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala accepted a
portion of that dua.
There was a kind of compromise.
He said, "And if it wasn't for me,"
meaning for his dua,
Abu Talib would have been in the lowest
level of hell.
Isn't that very interesting?
Because Abu Talib and that narration is
in that exact wording. And Abu Talib
what's very interesting about him is
that he spent his life after the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam became a
prophet advocating for him not
advocating for his prophethood
not advocating for his religion or his
cause but advocating for him as his as
his nephew that's a very important
distinction
right advocating for him as his nephew
but then he has other instances where he
admits
and conceds that
had it not been for the fact that I
feared my people insulting me
and had it not been for the fact that I
feared my people would look down upon
me, I would have become Muslim. And I'm
sure that Islam is true. This is in
private, not in public.
And I'm sure that the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam that Muhammad that my
nephew is a prophet from Allah. He is a
messenger. But what stopped him is
fear of his people. What stopped him is
that he wanted to keep up this charade.
And he said in his final breath
and his final breath what were his final
words?
Yes,
his final breath was used to say he is
upon the religion of
Abdalib.
So what really sent him to the place
that he ended up going, the place he is
right now, it was that he loved and felt
a loyalty
to the way of his heritage, the way of
his forefathers
more than the one who created him, Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala.
However, here's what's interesting.
If that's the case and his kufur is far
less intense than that of his
counterpart Abuahab,
right?
Why
did the prophet sallallah.aii wasallam
say, "And had it not been for my
intercession,
he would have been in the lowest part of
the fire." Why the lowest part?
He used a very specific word. He said,
meaning the lowest low level of the
fire. That place is reserved for who?
Hypocrites, right? And what is the main
defining feature of hypocrisy
is that the heart and the actions are
not in alignment. Correct?
We notice Abu Talib here heart and
actions were not in alignment. It was
the exact almost mirror image of
hypocrisy that happened in the time of
Medina in the era of Medina.
And so Abu Tal that that whole
idea of being one thing in private and
being something else in public is so
despicable to Allah.
Subhanahu wa ta'ala
that this is where Abu Talib would have
landed himself not because he didn't
reach out with an olive branch to the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam but but
because he failed his creator in every
significantly spiritual level. That is
why
Subhan Allah.
[Silence]
What's his brother's name?
[Arabic recitation]
you.
put it inside here.
[Arabic recitation]